it was another night of clashes in
Turkey's main city Istanbul right police
used armored vehicles and teargas to try
to disperse demonstrators they responded
with rocks and fireworks they're angry
at what they see as ed ones increasingly
authoritarian rule we're not going to
accept just a single idea we're single
point of view we as the Turkish people
we deserve better than this Turkish
security forces have been accused of
using excessive force against protesters
at a conference in Istanbul EU
enlargement Commissioner Stefan fula
said that member states have to protect
certain freedoms these include the
freedom to express one's opinion the
freedom to assemble peacefully and
freedom of media to report on what is
happening as it is happening but a
Dhawan has rejected accusations of
repressive leadership we have no qualms
or questions about freedom independence
the rule of law or the democratic
experience today the Turkish Republic is
closer to EU membership than it has ever
been more freedom more independence
that's exactly what these people say
they're demonstrating for